[Applaus]
britta haßelmann für die fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin sehr geehrte kolleginnen
kollegen
die bilder und nachrichten aus butscher
nun zwei tagen erreichen sind
schrecklich sie sind grausam die bilder
von feige ermordeten menschen von
massengräbern die verzweiflung und
tränen von müttern und vätern und
kindern haben uns alle ins mark
getroffen
es sind menschen wie sie und ich die bis
vor ein paar wochen noch ein ganz
normales leben frei und selbstbestimmt
mitten in europa geführt haben ich
möchte an dieser stelle dem präsidenten
see lenski und allen angehörigen
stellvertretend für so viele menschen in
der ukraine
mein tiefes mitgefühl aussprechen
auch hier
meine damen und herren herrscht
unfassbare trauer auch hier herrscht
unfassbare hut und auch wenn der kreml
versucht durch desinformation
lügen und propaganda
unbelegte zweifel zu säen und seiner
anhänger selbst hier in deutschland
versuchen diese zweifel und
desinformation und propaganda zu
verbreiten
eins ist doch klar hinter diesen
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit
steht putin und steht seine armee die
dokumentation der kriegsverbrechen und
die aufarbeitung müssen jetzt beginnen
putin und seine gefolgsleute werden sich
dafür vor dem internationalen
strafgericht verantworten müssen
meine damen und herren
sie wurde die zerstörung und die gold
hatten zeitnah furchtbarste weise mit
welcher unfassbaren brutalität
der russische präsident seinen krieg
gegen die ukrainische zivilbevölkerung
führt die kriegsverbrechen der
russischen armee können wir nicht
unbeantwortet lassen wir müssen
gemeinsam mit unseren europäischen
partnern mit g7 im transatlantischen
bündnis
alles was möglich es tun diese
unmenschliche brutalität ein zu dem der
druck auf putin und sein system auf die
die ihn stützen muss dringend erhöht
werden ich hoffe darüber besteht konsens
den demokratinnen und demokraten dieses
hauses es kommt er auf ein gemeinsames
entschlossen des europäisches und
internationales vorgehen an schärfere
sanktionen werden wir jetzt in diesen
tagen in diesen stunden in einem fünf
sanktionspaket in der europäischen
kommission in der europäischen
gemeinschaft beschließen um den druck
auf putins machtapparat auf sein system
weiter zu erhöhen dazu gehören
einfuhrverbote für kohle dazu gehören
transaktions verbote gegen wichtige
weitere russische banken ein weiteres
einfrieren von vermögenswerten und
einiges mehr was die europäischen
staaten gemeldet haben und was notwendig
ist die sanktionen wirklich zu
verschärfen und einfach noch mehr druck
über dieses sanktionsregime auszulösen
dieses paket wird auch das fundament für
einen komplettausstieg aus der
abhängigkeit von russlands fossiler
energie und damit dass putin regime auch
klar klar noch jagd hat treffen als es
das mit den bisherigen sanktions paketen
den 14 schon tut härtere sanktionen und
der weg raus aus den fossilen energien
russlands werden von den europäerinnen
und europäern gemeinsam gegangen und
zwar so schnell wie möglich und das ist
die wichtige nachricht wir müssen an
dieser stelle gemeinsam handeln
entschlossen hier und jetzt unser ziel
muss es sein muss
wirtschaftlich und finanziell zu koppeln
oder anderen ländern zu schaden gerade
den ärmeren ländern das muss uns gelingt
diese klare internationale und
europäische haltung diese gemeinsame
antwort das ist das worauf es jetzt
ankommt meine damen und herren und dazu
gehören auch die waffenlieferungen und
dazu gehört auch die frage alles was
machbar ist im europäischen kontext zu
diskutieren und dies auch gemeinsam
jetzt auf den weg zu bringen im hinblick
auf waffenlieferungen und das sage ich
für meine fraktion genauso überzeugt wie
andere hier im haus und wie wir in der
europäischen gemeinsam gemeinschaft vor
völlig zusammen meine damen und herren
putin muss diesen krieg gegen die
ukraine und gegen diese verbrechen gegen
die menschlichkeit sofort stoppen und
ich bin mir sicher wir werden gemeinsam
mit unseren partnern in europa im
transatlantischen bündnis mit der
verschärfung der sanktionen mit der
unterstützung liegen recht auf
selbstverteidigung durch
waffenlieferungen und humanitäre hilfe
alles was machbar ist tun um diese diese
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit zu
stoppen vielen dank
vorsitzende der fraktion bündnis 90/die
grünen im bundestag in der aktuellen
stunde zu massakern der russischen
truppen an ukrainischen zivilisten und
jetzt kommt johann wadephul
stellvertretender vorsitzender der
unionsfraktion und danach die
bundesverteidigungsministerium christine
lambrecht
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich kann mich der kollegin kasselmann
nur vollkommen
anschließen das ist nicht nur ein
völkerrechtswidriger krieg das ist ein
krieg der unter verletzung der grund
normen der humanität und verletzung der
grund normen der genfer
konvention geführt wird der keine
rücksicht mehr nimmt auf schwache
menschen auch kinder frauen auf
schwangere auf altem das ist ein
krieg der auf apathische art und weise
geführt wird und in der tat ich schließe
mich ihre aufforderung an und bin für
meine fraktion gerne bereit das zu
erklären hier müssen wir zusammenstehen
und gemeinsam auf der richtigen seite
stehen und gemeinsam auf der seite der
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer stehen mal
gesagt hätten
ich will aber einräumt frau kollegin
dass ich mir so klare worte wie sie von
ihm gehört habe wie ich sie auch von
frau strack-zimmermann lese von annalena
baerbock auch weitgehend höre auch vom
bundeskanzler gewünscht hätte ja ich
höre nicht damit auf weil er vorhin hier
fresken in einer fragestunde fragen
ausgewichen ist unklar geblieben ist und
sich zu dieser frage nicht äußern hatte
gegen jede woche auch die gelegenheit
hätte klar zu sagen wofür steht meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren so ein
krieg kann
prinzipiell drei auswege haben dann die
eine seite gewinnen das kann die andere
seite gewinnen und es kann ein
verständigung skride geben nachdem wir
das letztere in dieser
auseinandersetzung glaube ich nicht
erwarten können müssen wir uns
entscheiden auf welcher seite wir mit
welchen mitteln stehen wollen und da
kann ich nur sagen in dieser situation
wir wollten nie wir wollen nicht an dem
krieg vor mehr teilnehmen aber in dieser
situation muss deutschland muss die
freie welt wirklich aber auch alles tun
dass putin diesen krieg nicht gewinnt
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
das würde
das würde das wurde das wäre eine das
würde eine grosse niederlage für uns
alle sein das wäre eine niederlage für
deutschland das wäre eine niederlage für
menschenrechte das wäre eine niederlage
für die europäische union es wäre im
übrigen für alle staaten auf der welt
die das unterstützt haben auch in den
vereinten nationen an die niederlage es
wäre eine niederlage für den präsidenten
der vereinigten staaten von amerika und
wir alle oder films hat viele von uns
die allermeisten von uns nicht sagen
weil die demokratische mit den
jedenfalls wünscht sich ja kaum dass er
trump wieder zum präsidenten der
vereinigten staaten von amerika gewählt
wird das heißt didier schluss muss doch
sein dass wir jetzt in dieser und
situation wirklich alles tun was in
unseren möglichkeiten steht in der tat
unterhalb einer formellen beteiligung
der nato und der bundeswehr dass dieser
krieg von den ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
gewonnen wird dass sie sich erfolgreich
verteidigen können meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren und da muss ich sagen
finden die ich an der stelle wo es geht
weil sie es nicht runde und der
bundeskanzler ihrer antwort von vorhin
da musste man ja bei der dritten
nachfrage versuchen herauszulesen was
sagen sie denn nun zum thema schwere
waffen es ist eine binnen sind man mag
es nicht schön finden aber es ist eine
militärische pinsel dass in dieser
situation des krieges die ukraine
renault kreiner wenn sie sich
erfolgreich verteidigen sollen schweres
gerät brauchen gepanzerte waffen
bergepanzer brücken lege panzer
vielleicht sogar kampf band sein
vielleicht sogar artillerie geschosse
die brauchen sie nun mal um bestehen zu
können
und da muss ich ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen
wenn die antwort heute hier ist da
sollte deutschland nicht vorpreschen da
sollten wir nicht die ersten sein die
das machen dann ist das aus meiner sicht
eine unzureichende antwort dann wird
deutschland seiner verantwortung für die
agrar für die ukraine in dieser
historischen situation schlicht nicht
kriegt meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren das muss man sagen ja ich will
ihnen das ganz offen sagen ich habe das
von der frage gesagt ich kenne
geschäftsführer von rüstungsunternehmen
die sagen mir sie haben jede woche
wieder bei einem referatsleiter im
bundeswirtschaftsministerium zu tun die
ihn fragen stellt die der bundeskanzler
hat freunde auch angedeutet hat können
die ukraine denn überhaupt mit den
waffen umgehen wo wollt ihr die
übergeben können die ukrainerin ukrainer
das überhaupt bezahlen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren wenn wir auf
diesem bürokratischen niveau am ende die
ganze geschichte kaputt machen wollen
dann sagen sie es bitte ehrlich ich bin
der meinung wir stehen auf der seite der
ukraine und müssen das dann auch leisten
und dazu gehört auch die frage der
energieversorgung die natürlich keine
kleine frage ist und das will ich auch
nicht abschließend hier sagen dass ich
alles beurteilen kann nur wenn robert
habeck sagt also wenn wir das abschalten
ist es eine katastrophe
aber wenn putin das macht dann ist es
beherrschbar ist mindestens mal ein
offenkundiger logischer widerspruch und
deswegen sage ich diese bundesregierung
dass aus der unentschiedenheit
herauskommen sie muss ich klar bekennen
sie muss eine führungsrolle unternehmen
sie muss wo sie wissen wo sie steht in
dieser situation und erst recht nach
butscher an der seite der ukraine an der
seite der mitmenschlichkeit herzlichen
dank
haben war der folie stellvertretender
vorsitzender der unionsfraktion fordert
mehr führung von der bundesregierung in
der aktuellen lage darauf kann jetzt
reagieren die
bundesverteidigungsministerium christine
lambrecht zuletzt für auftreten und
agieren auch und vor allem mit
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine
wiederholt kritisiert frau präsidentin
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren die
bilder die uns aus der ukraine erreichen
sie sind schrecklich sie zeigen total
sste gräueltaten an zivilisten begangen
werden und
unsere gedanken sind bei den opfern und
ihren angehörigen
wenn wir ehrlich sind dann ist dieser
angriffskrieg dieser brutale
angriffskrieg schon ein verbrechen aber
das was wir da gesehen haben was wir da
sehen müssen das ist eine
entmenschlichung die alle grenzen
überschritten hat und
was da ist
putin nimmt diese grauenvollen diese
grausamen taten in kauf aber es wäre zu
kurz gesprungen wenn wir das alles nur
auf protein reduzieren würden es sind
nämlich nicht nur seine taten sondern
jeder kommandant der so etwas befehligt
jeder soldat der so eine tat ausführt
oder geschehen lässt der macht sich
mindestens genauso schuldig meine damen
und
alle müssen sich fragen lassen ist das
dass russland für das ihr die uniform
trägt für das wir stehen volt ist das
dass russland für das ihr kämpft und die
internationale gemeinschaft die muss
klar antworten jede tat muss
schonungslos verfolgt werden und es muss
alles dafür getan werden alles dass
wirklich jeder einzelne kriegsverbrecher
auf seine entsprechende harte strafe
bekommen
aber wir sehen in den straßen von
butscher mehr als nur leichen in deren
straßen wir sehen im grellen licht die
grausamkeit des system putins es ist ein
system dem alle mittel recht sind um
seine interessen durchzusetzen ein
system das nationalistischen großmacht
zwar alles unterordnet dass keine
grenzen kennt und keine hemmung ein
system das recht und menschlichkeit mit
füßen tritt und deswegen darf dieses
system nicht gewinnen es darf sich nicht
durchsetzen wer so handelt wie putin dem
ist es egal ob die leichen auf den
strassen von butscher oder leichen auf
den strassen von tiflis vilnius oder
berlin sind und daher müssen wir die
ukraine in ihrem kampf gegen das system
putin stützen unterstützen wo wir nur
können und dabei geht es nicht darum und
dabei geht es nicht darum schlagzeilen
zu produzieren oder sich moralisch zu
erleichtern nein es geht darum ganz
konkret zu helfen ganz konkret zu
unterstützen
denn wir können diesen krieg so sehr
schmerzt nicht mit einem schlag beenden
und aber wir können wir können die
russische fähigkeit zur kriegsführung
schwächen wir haben bereits beispiellos
harte sanktionen erlassen sanktionen die
russland an das land an den rand eines
staatsbankrotts gebracht haben und die
zunehmend ihre volle wirkung entfalten
und jetzt werden wir noch einmal
entschlossen und gezielt nachlegen und
dabei dank auch den import von
energieträgern im blick haben ganz
aktuell das vorgeschlagene importverbot
für russische kohle ist dabei ein ganz
wichtiger baustein
meine damen und herren wir haben die
ukraine bereits in großem umfang auch
mit waffen beliefert unterstützt und wir
arbeiten jeden tag mit hochdruck daran
weitere
waffen liefern zu können und dafür sind
wir im ständigen austausch mit der
ukrainischen regierung mit unseren
alliierten und partnern
und auch mit der rüstungsindustrie
wenn wir über die art und anzahl der
gelieferten waffen aber nicht öffentlich
reden dann hat das einen guten grund die
ukraine hat ausdrücklich darum gebeten
und wir halten uns daran es geht aus
militärischer sicht nämlich darum dass
russland im unklaren über die typen und
mengen der gelieferten waffen ist und
sich nicht darauf einstellen kann der
feind hört nämlich mit und deswegen ist
es so wichtig dass wir handeln aber
nicht darüber reden weil das würde das
ziel gefährden nämlich die ukraine zu
unterstützen
und er war der pole dass es kein keine
bürokratische hürde in diesem
zusammenhang ist eines ganz wichtig die
nato und deutschland darf nicht
riskieren selbst zur kriegspartei zu
werden denn das ist für ganz ganz viele
menschen eine große sorge momentan wie
geht das weiter wie wirkt sich das aus
was bedeutet das auch für uns wie
entwickelt sich diese spirale das kann
man nicht einfach als bürokratische
hürde aktion nein dieser verantwortung
müssen wir nachkommen und da sind wir
uns mit unseren verbündeten in der nato
mit unseren partnern in der europäischen
union sehr sehr einig dass wir diese
grenze nicht überschreiten wollen und
auch nicht überschreiten werden wir
müssen verhindern dass es einen
flächenbrand in europa in europa gibt
mit allen sich daraus ergebenden
schrecklichen konsequenzen
man lernt das system putin darf nicht
gewinnen darf sich nicht durchsetzen
denn sonst können wir uns alle nicht
mehr sicher seien und daher müssen wir
auch in deutschland lernen sehr viel
wehrhafter zu sein sehr viel wehrhaft da
zu sein und dieser gedanke steht hinter
der sicherheitspolitischen zeitenwende
die der bundeskanzler verkündet hat
dieser gedanke steht hinter dem
sondervermögen von 100 milliarden euro
für die bundeswehr wenn wir heute in
unserer streitkräfte investieren dann
geht es nämlich darum unsere werte von
recht und menschlichkeit gegen das
system putin zu verteidigen da geht es
darum uns und unsere verbündeten gegen
militärische erpressung und gewalt
abzusichern vielen dank
christine lambrecht
bundesverteidigungsminister wenn in der
aktuellen stunde zu massakern von
russischen soldaten spricht
der ukrainischen stadt im boccia und der
nächste redner es jürgen braun aus der
fdp fraktion sprecher für menschenrechte
und humanitäre hilfe
frau präsidentin
liebe kollegen um meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren roger war eine ruhige
kleinstadt unmittelbar vor den toren
kirche mit einem großen see und viel
grün das käfer großbürgertum der
vorrevolutionären zeit vor dorthin in
die sommerfrische wie man damals
hierzulande gesagt hätte nichts erinnert
jetzt mehr an diese vergangenheit denn
bis vor wenigen tagen sollten leichen
die straßen butchers wie während des
holodomor des kommunistischen
völkermords an den ukrainer
natürlich kann in jedem krieg nicht nur
der aggressor kriegsverbrechen begehen
sondern ebenso der verteidiger wir als
fdp fordern eine zweistufige
untersuchung zunächst
möglichst schnell durch die drei
experten die der uno menschenrechtsrat
erst letzte woche für die ukraine
benannt hat der norwegische chef
ermittler dieser kommission hat schon
dass ruanda tribunal geleitet und als
zweite stufe falls die kommission zu
entsprechenden ergebnissen gelangt ein
kriegsverbrechertribunal wie zum
ehemaligen jugoslawien dass eine
lückenlose aufklärung ohne ansehen der
kriegspartei leistet
was es aber jetzt schon gibt es in
satellitenaufnahmen und zeugenberichte
tatiana wladimirowna eine alte frau aus
butscher erzählt wie er mann getötet
wurde drei soldaten darunter ein
tschetschene stürmten ihre wohnung
misshandelten und
verschleppten ihn
ihr hatte der tschetschene mit schlägen
gedroht falls sie sich widersetzte sie
suchte ihren mann anschließend tagelang
bei der russischen armee gab man ihr
keine auskunft eine freundin sagte er
schließlich es seien leichen im keller
eines nachbarhauses gefunden worden
tatiana erkannte ihren mann nur an den
turnschuhen so entstellt war die leiche
und begraben muss die sie ihn gemeinsam
mit freunden denn die russischen truppen
kümmerten sich nicht einmal darum die
leichen zu verscharren
die betrachtung prima phase also der
erste anschein spricht für die klare
täterschaft einer bestimmten seite und
sollte sich das als wahr erweisen dann
muss dieses grausame handeln
konsequenzen nach sich ziehen
befragt nach dem hintergrund solcher
verbrechen erklärte der osteuropa
historiker jörg borowski zitat die
soldaten der russischen armee werden
mangelhaft versorgt leiden hunger und
frieren sie werden von ihren offizieren
tyrannisiert menschen die solche
behandlung ausgesetzt sind geraten außer
sich sobald sich ihnen eine gelegenheit
bietet andere menschen genauso zu
behandeln
überzeugt davon am 31 märz suchen sich
die russischen streitkräfte zurück am
ersten april nahm die ukrainische armee
die stadt ein das erste video
ausrutscher noch weitgehend unbeachtet
von den westlichen medien ist am selben
tag aufgetaucht und amerikanischen
satelliten aufnahmen zeigen inzwischen
dass die leichen tage lang dort lagen
trotzdem werde dem russischen
staatsfernsehen behauptet alles sei
arrangiert hier leichten gar keine
leichen die ersten aufnahmen erst tage
nach der rückeroberung
aufgetaucht und die russische propaganda
wird auch vom deutschen staat funk
genährt der bundesweiten tk georg reste
der noch vor kurzem putin als
realpolitiker gelobt hat erklärt uns
jetzt die ukraine hätten journalisten
keinen zugang zu bewerten dabei hatte
die ard über wochen gar keinen eigenen
reporter in kiew trotz zwangsgebühren in
milliarden höhe
plötzlich entdeckt auch die nun
oppositionelle cdu ihren
widerstandsgeist ihre vorsitzende angela
merkel hat doch erst dafür gesorgt dass
deutschland derart abhängig von
russischem gas wurde und zwar mit ihrem
kopflosen links grünen atomausstieg
und es ist auch merkels er wird wenn
bundeskanzler scholz der teilweisen
stift abschaltung russlands erst als
letzter eu regierungschefs zustimmen so
an nach viktor orban den sie liebe
kollegen von der union jahrelang putin
freund beschimpft haben
exemplarisch für den umgang unserer
regierung mit dem ukraine krieg steht
eine szene aus dem
menschenrechtsausschuss die ich vor zwei
wochen mit erlebt habe die kollegin
engelhardt von der spd klagte bei einer
unterrichtung dass die ukraine transfer
nicht als frauen sondern als männer
betrachtet und für sie der wehrdienst
gelte und die genossen fragte erster
ernsthaft ob sich die bundesregierung
dafür einsetzen dass die ukraine auch
trans frauen als frauen anerkennen werde
das ist leider kein witz was die ukraine
jetzt braucht sind keine belehrung in
sachen gander das ist sogar das letzte
was sie jetzt braucht fast die ukraine
braucht das ist ein starkes wehrhaftes
europa der vaterländer vielen dank
der sprecher für menschenrechte und
humanitäre hilfe in der afg fraktion und
in dieser half die fraktion so ist zu
hören wird extrem kontrovers diskutiert
über den umgang mit russland und auch
mit dem krieg der russen gegen die
ukraine bijan djir sarai ist der nächste
redner aus der fdp fraktion in der fdp
ist der generalsekretär und im bundestag
mitglied im auswärtigen ausschuss
die grauenvollen bilder die uns seit dem
vergangenen wochenende aus roger
erreichen sind unerträglich
mit dem rückzug der russischen truppen
aus dem großraum kiel wird das ausmaß
der zerstörung und der barbarei immer
deutlicher vor den augen der ganzen welt
bricht putins russland das völkerrecht
mit einer brutalität die ihresgleichen
sucht
bis vor einer woche hatte ich den namen
noch nie gehört bis vor einer woche bis
vor einer woche wusste ich nicht einmal
wo dieser ort auf der landkarte liegt
ich bin mir aber sicher
das künftige generation ob in der
ukraine in deutschland oder in ganz
europa wissen werden was in botschaft
passiert ist und wofür dieser ort steht
roger steht für unfassbar viel leid
gewalt und grauenhafte verbrechen
satellitenbildern zufolge liegen dort
die toten männer frauen und kinder seien
wochen auf den straßen teilweise
gefesselt geknebelt und
mit spuren von vergewaltigungen
ohnmacht angst hilflosigkeit
noch immer habe ich das gesicht von
präsident alan ski vor augen denn mit
ausländischen journalisten durch butter
geht damit diese der welt zeigen können
welche grausamen massaker an
unschuldigen zivilisten begangen wurden
sein gesichtsausdruck
spiegelt all jene gefühle wider die so
viele ukrainische mütter väter und
angehörige in diesen tagen schmerzhaft
durch legen
die toten von butscher
sie alle fanden freunde und verwandte
sie alle waren menschen mit träumen und
sorgen für das leben sie alle hatten
individuellen biografien und sie alle
waren einzigartig
ich weiß nicht was wir noch viel bilder
zu sehen bekommen werden aber ich
befürchte dass die grausamen bilder aus
butter nur die spitze des eisberges sind
meine damen und herren in den letzten
tagen ist viel über die deutsche außen-
und sicherheitspolitik gesprochen worden
sehr oft habe ich in den letzten tagen
gehört dass wir alle naiv gegenüber
russland gewesen sind und putin falsch
eingeschätzt haben diese fehler dürfen
sich nicht wiederholen und gerade jetzt
in dieser situation dürfen wir erst
recht nicht naiv sein der westen
der westen hat nach dem georgien krieg
nicht entschlossen gegenüber putin
reagiert der westen hat nicht
geschlossen auf die krim alexion
reagiert der westen hat sich im
wesentlichen weggedreht als russland in
syrien ganze städte und dörfer
ausradiert hat wir müssen uns darüber im
klaren sein solange dieses regime
existiert meine damen und herren wird es
keine sicherheit in europa geben
jürgen
künftige künftige generationen werden
uns die frage stellen egal ob regierung
oder opposition
werden uns die frage stellen wie wir uns
in diesen schicksalsstunde europas
verhalten haben wir sind es nicht nur
den opfern dieses krieges schuldig wir
sind es uns auch selbst schuldig jede
form der wirtschaftlichen zusammenarbeit
mit diesem regime ist eine schande und
muss schnellstmöglich beendet werden
meine damen und herren
deutschland und europa zeigen sich
dieser dunklen stunde der europäischen
geschichte solidarisch mit der ukraine
nicht nur mit schönen worten auch mit
taten weitere taten um handlungen müssen
folgen eine breit gefächerte
unterstützung der ukrainischen
streitkräfte ist von äußerster
wichtigkeit
jetzt ist die zeit gekommen russland
klar zu machen dass die beziehung zum
westen endgültig zu bruch gegangen es
solange putin die macht im kreml innehat
die welt wird die gräueltaten von
butscher niemals vergessen wir werden
und müssen alles dafür tun dass die
farbe dass die verantwortlichen für
diese verbrechen zur rechenschaft
gezogen werden meine damen und herren
putin hat versucht mit seinen brutalen
angriffskrieg die ukraine zu vernichten
und den westen zu spalten das ist ihm
nicht gelungen meine damen und herren
und das wird ihm auch nicht gelingen
wir stehen fest an der seite aller
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
die diesen schweren tagen um ihre
freiheit und ihr leben kämpfen salvá
ukraine
[Applaus]
für die für die linke ergreift der
kollege dr liebt das wort
[Applaus]
sidentin meine damen und herren die
bilder aus butter sind unerträglich tote
männer frauen kinder
kaltblütig ermordet auf offener straße
auf dem fahrrad unschuldige bürgerinnen
und bürger auf der straße wieder
liegengelassen in massengräbern
verscharrt
was den bus ja getan wurde ist ein
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit sind
kriegsverbrechen die verantwortlichen
für diese baureihe gehören schonungslos
ermittelt sie müssen vor einem gericht
für foltern und für ihr morgen zur
verantwortung gezogen worden und dafür
müssen wir alles tun
bei damen und herren die politische
fahren die politische verantwortung für
die toten von butscher trägt wladimir
putin ich wiederhole heute hier russland
präsident ist ein kriegsverbrecher seine
entscheidung am 24 februar die ukraine
zu überfallen hat den grundstein für die
verbrechen gelegt die seit diesem tag
die ukraine heimsuchen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen butscher bestürzt und auch
deshalb weil sich das grauen abbildet
weil uns fotos und videos erreichen weil
augenzeugen schildern welche treue
begangen wurden und ich will uns alle
mal ermahnen eine sekunde an die vielen
geflüchteten zu denken die diese bilder
auch sehen und die vielfach jetzt schon
traumatisiert sind ich glaube das
sollten wir bei uns und argumenten auch
mit beachten die kollegen überlegen
machen wir uns nichts vor butscher ist
nicht der ort von kriegsverbrechen
butchers ein hort von kriegsverbrechen
weitere bilder des horrors werden uns
erreichen werden journalistinnen und
journalisten in andere orte und städte
der
vordringen weil die wenigen bilder sieht
die uns aus mario pohl zum beispiel
erreichen ahnt welche dramatik wir noch
zu erwarten haben die all ihre kollegen
um das hier zu sagen die verantwortung
für den krieg und die verbrechen trägt
russland niemand in deutschland deswegen
sich das klar sagen dass angela merkel
und frank walter steinmeier ja von
einigen die ich ansonsten viel zu
kritisieren hatte von einigen zu
helfershelfern das russischen
präsidenten erklärt werden das ist
zutiefst unanständig und das ist auch
beschämt meine damen und herren es geht
hier nicht um schlagzeilen wer versucht
nämlich den krieg in der ukraine
parteipolitisch zu instrumentalisieren
der leistet keinen beitrag den krieg zu
beenden würden der spiel der russische
propaganda eines gespaltenen bestens in
die karten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
verbrechen dieses krieges werden enden
wenn dieser verbrecherischen krieg endet
denn kriegsverbrechen kriegsverbrechen
sind kriegen immer nennt und zwar allen
kriegen mein eindruck ist dass eine hier
davon ausgehen dass der krieg in wenigen
wochen beendet sein kann dass es die
eine exportierte waffe gibt oder die
eine sanktion die putin zur kapitulation
zwingen ich halte das offen gestanden
für wenig wahrscheinlich
dieser krieg kann auch noch lange
andauern und da hilft es auch nicht
jeden tag lieber kollege wadephul mit
der rüstungsindustrie kontakt zu haben
das ist etwas entlarvend dass hier
sozusagen meine damen und herren
wir befinden uns in einem moralischen
dilemma ganz gleich ob für
energieimporte die kriegt nur direkt
oder indirekt finanzieren aber erklären
sie mir doch bitte einen sachverhalt der
frischen in der fragestunde eine rolle
spielte sehr geehrter herr bundeskanzler
warum schafft es belgien
vermögenswerte russische oligarchen in
höhe von zehn milliarden euro
einzufrieren warum schafft es frankreich
850 millionen einzuführen italien hat
mehrere hundert millionen euro
beschlagnahmen und deutschland liegt bei
95 millionen desto unfassbar warum
funktioniert das er nicht warum versagt
deutschland bei der durchsetzung der
sanktionen gegen russische oligarchen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
akademische herrsche also kontraste nach
der haben russische investoren allein in
berlin seit 2014 und wir alle wissen was
2014 war immobilien im wert von
442 millionen erworben und sie stehen
aktuell bei 95 millionen für ganz
deutschland beschlagnahmtes vermögen das
ist wirklich unfassbar wie man sie haben
am 15 märz eine task force gegründet ist
er richtig und zuständig sind die
ministerien von herrn hamberg und herr
linder man hört relativ viel von den
beiden herren nur dazu überhaupt nichts
und das muss sich ändern herr scholz
machen sie das zur chefsache
die verantwortung dafür gehört ins
kanzleramt dieses geld muss für den
wiederaufbau der op eingesetzt werden
meine damen und herren ja lassen sie uns
alles tun dass der krieg beendet wird
nur das wird verbrechen wie die in
butter auch beenden erst dann kann
die frau war dass hier der
fraktionsvorsitzende der linksfraktion
in dieser aktuellen stunde auf die sich
die abgeordneten des deutschen
bundestags geeinigt haben so gamers
ackermann ukrainischen zivilisten im
liga- und kollegen und ich erteile das
wort dem nächsten redner michael rothe
spd fraktion und ihn so gut ist
vorsitzender des auswärtigen ausschusses
vielen dank liebe frau präsidentin
kolleginnen und kollegen roger wird sich
sicherlich tief in das kollektive
gedächtnis nicht nur der ukrainerinnen
und ukrainer sondern von uns allen den
europäerinnen und europäern einbringen
aber vergessen wir nicht
wo er steht nicht für sich allein
botschaft eine vorgeschichte es ist ein
epo es ist grosny sind viele andere orte
wo putin in aller brutalität gezeigt hat
wozu er bereit und imstande ist um seine
interessen knallhart entmenschlicht
durchzusetzen und wir erleben derzeit
auch in der ukraine selbst viel zu viele
orte wo tagtäglich
zivilistinnen und zivilisten einen
furchtbaren tod sterben aber liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen dieser
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine war von
anfang an
verbrecherisch
frevelhaft verwerflich und grausam und
es ist sehr bitter die sagen zu müssen
es ist nicht nur putins krieg viele
russen und russen
unterstützen putin und das sagt er ja so
selbst in seinem kampf um die befreiung
der ukraine vom faschismus wie furchtbar
und wie schlimm muss das vor allem auch
in unseren augen und in unseren ohren
klingen
und das wird bittere konsequenzen haben
denn niemand kann sich darauf einstellen
dass dieses furchtbare regime unter
führung von putin so schnell aus den
angeln gehoben werden wird sondern wir
werden uns auf absehbare zeit vermutlich
noch mit diesem regime
auseinanderzusetzen haben und es wird
darum gehen ob die europäische union die
demokratien die liberalen gesellschaften
diesem acht einzel gegen in der lage
sind über
die zukunft europas wird in diesen tagen
wochen und monaten nicht in berlin nicht
in paris nicht in rom nicht in stockholm
sondern in mario pohl in charkiw und
butscher entschieden
wenn russland diesen furchtbaren krieg
gewinnen sollte dann drohen weitere
militärische konflikte in moldau in
georgien möglicherweise auch in anderen
staaten des östlichen europas es zieht
sich bis in den westlichen balkan wo wir
derzeit sezession beschreibungen bosnien
herzegowina erleben die aktiv und
völlig unmoralisch und völlig kalt und
brutal von putin unterstützt werden
frieden und sicherheit in ganz europa
auch unsere eigene sicherheit in
deutschland ist nur dann möglich wenn
die ukraine frei und souverän bleibt
putin hat diesen krieg zwar moralisch
wirtschaftlich politisch längst verloren
aber er muss und er wird ihn auch
militärisch verlieren und das wird
maßgeblich davon abhängen wie wir die
ukraine in diesen dramatischen zeiten
unterstützen liebe kollegin kollegen aus
fast allen fraktionen
gehen derzeit abgeordnete unsere
regierung auf die nerven wir sind
ungeduldig wir fragen uns tagtäglich in
jeder stunde was können wir noch mehr
tun wo müssen wir noch aktiver werden wo
können wir noch mehr humanitäre hilfe
leisten wo können wir noch mehr für den
schutz der ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
tun ja wo können wir auch noch mehr
militärische unterstützung leisten und
dabei geht es um alle waffen die die
ukraine benötigt die schnell und sicher
geliefert werden können und die eben
auch leicht bedienbar sind damit sich
die ukraine zu verteidigen vermag jeden
tag den die ukraine länder frei und
souverän bleibt werden chancen für eine
lösung am verhandlungstisch
wahrscheinlicher nur aus einer position
der stärke und der wehrhaftigkeit heraus
hat die ukraine eine chance zu überleben
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und es mag ein schwacher trost sein aber
ich will es trotzdem wenigstens einmal
gesagt haben was uns gemeinsam gelungen
ist ist dass die europäische und die
europäische union die nato geschlossen
und entschlossen zusammen stehen so viel
teamgeist hat es vermutlich schon seit
vielen jahren und jahrzehnten in diesem
vereinten europa nicht mehr gegeben
machen wir etwas daraus und vor allem
muss das jetzt auch für die weiteren
sanktionen gelten
wir müssen uns hier auf fragen was
können wir tun um noch mehr druck auf
russland auch putin auf die oligarchen
ausüben zu können und ich finde es ist
die pflicht der bundesregierung alle
maßnahmen auf soziale wirtschaftliche
politische folgen hin zu überprüfen das
wird uns bisweilen in ein furchtbares
moralisches dilemma bringen aber es muss
klar sein dass am ende wir auch zu
weitreichenden entscheidungen bereit
sind aber wir müssen die bürgerinnen und
bürger unseres landes mitnehmen nur ein
starkes deutschland kann europa bei
dieser bewährungsprobe helfen und nur
ein starkes deutschland ist im übrigen
auch gut für die ukraine denn dann
kommen sie wirklich zum schluss machen
können wenn solidarität ausüben um die
wir immer wieder gebeten werden und wir
sollten die ausgestreckte hand der
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer in größter
not annehmen das ist unsere pflicht und
das ist unsere schuldigkeit
nicht so gut aber das hat hier
gesprochene vorsitzende des auswärtigen
ausschusses seit beginn des ukraine
krieges ist die debatte in deutschland
welche waffen geliefert werden ob gewinn
waffen geliefert werden und bisher hieß
es immer schwere waffen wie panzer oder
auch kriegsschiffe kommen nicht in frage
diese debatte ist aber durch die
gräueltaten jetzt wieder im vollen gange
präsidentin kolleginnen und kollegen
ist es das bild der rot lackierten
fingernägel eine ermordeten frau
ist es der schlüsselbund mit europafahne
neben der hand eines weiteren ermordeten
zivilisten
oder ist es doch die laut tönende
sprachlosigkeit
präsident zement kies in butter die uns
ebenso fassungslos sprachlos macht es
sind blicke auf schwerste
menschenrechtsverletzungen und
schlimmstes kriegsverbrechen die uns aus
der ukraine erreichen und nicht nur sie
zeigen es geht bei diesem angriffskrieg
von putin und seine schergen um die
systematische zerstörung eines ganzen
volkes einer freiheitlichen nation hier
ist ein kriegsverbrecher am werk der
keine grenzen mehr kennt aber sehen wir
solche bilder wirklich zum ersten mal
nur 45 kilometer von bayern entfernt
liegt auch war im jahr
1941 ermordete hier die ss tausende
jüdische männer und frauen und kinder
vor genau 30 jahren nachher kommt die
debatte noch in diesem haus begann die
belagerung der bosnischen hauptstadt
sarajevo was folgte war das schreckliche
sterben von srebrenica
haben wir das noch alles in erinnerung
deshalb kolleginnen und kollegen gegen
doch heute umso mehr die situation in
der ukraine ist fundamental und
historisch der ausgang dieses krieges
hat vor allem auswirkungen für die
menschen dort aber auch für unsere
eigene zukunft eu nato und weite teile
der staatengemeinschaft stehen zusammen
ein sanktionspaket folgt dem nächsten
und ja so lambrecht es gilt kein eigenes
militärisches einschreiten um einen noch
größeren weltenbrand zu verhindern aber
dann müssen wir doch diejenigen die am
ende auch unsere freiheit verteidigen
und das ist wörtlich zu nehmen in die
lage umfassend versetzen dies tun zu
können
auch unser land gut vieles sicher allein
die hilfsbereitschaft unzähliger
menschen in diesem land ist unschätzbar
aber ich stelle dennoch die frage kann
diese bundesregierung mit ruhigem
gewissen sagen wir tun wirklich alles um
putin zu stoppen muss man nicht viel
mehr sagen von anfang an stand der
eindruck im raum deutschland reagiert
mehr als es agiert und das oft auch nur
ausdruck von außen zumeist auf den
letzten metern bis heute die regierung
hat beschlossen waffen zu liefern so der
bundeskanzler vor wenigen minuten an
anderer stelle noch hier in diesem hause
das ist gut aber herr bundeskanzler zur
wahrheit gehört doch aus dass wir es
erst getan haben als
alle anderen partner bereits ihre waffen
auf den weg gebracht hatten das gehört
zur wahrheit dazu wir liefern zu wenig
zu langsam und zu spät kolleginnen und
kollegen die weitere entwicklung in
diesem krieg werden schneller sein als
wir es heute erwarten das ahnen wir doch
jetzt schon auch beim thema energie dies
dieses land ist diese regierung darauf
vorbereitet deshalb liefern sie umgehend
die waffen die die ukraine jetzt
benötigt und nicht die sie
gegebenenfalls selbst für sinnvoll
halten es ist möglich vor allem setzen
sie sich bei allen sanktionen an die
spitze der bewegung das ist keine hybris
es wird von uns erwartet aktuell prüfen
sie ein eigenes gesetz ob sie es machen
müssen um rechtssicherheit zu bekommen
bei der umsetzung der sanktionen
okay aber
kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben in
der zwischenzeit das fünfte
sanktionspaket und jetzt fängt
deutschland an zu prüfen ob wir diese
überhaupt rechtssicher umsetzen können
kein wunder dass sie frauen gestellt
bekommen hier aus diesem hause bezüglich
der vermögenswerte und wie viel sie
davon schon einfrieren konnten der
ukraine hingegen der läuft die zeit
davon
putin darf diesen krieg nicht gewinnen
darüber sind wir uns hier alle einig
aber dann
übernehmen sie sichtbar verantwortung
und führung in deutschland in europa in
der gemeinschaft unserer partner
fehlender
patricia lips fordert zur eile auf
nächster redner ist jürgen trittin er
ist der außenpolitische sprecher von
bündnis 90 die grünen hier im deutschen
bundestag
und der nächste redner in der debatte
ist jürgen trittin bündnis 90/die
kraut für sie denken meine damen und
herren von clausewitz stammt der satz
dass krieg nur die fortsetzung der
politik mit anderen mitteln sein welche
politik wurde in butter mit morden an
kindern an frauen an alten mit folter
mit vergewaltigung fortgesetzt dort in
butter setzte das russische militär
putins politik um putin der im juli
davon sprach die ukraine bedürfe keine
eigenstaatlichkeit es gebe eine
einheitliche nation von kleinen russen
so nannte er die ukraine von bio russen
und russen
der genau dieses auf den weg gebracht
habe in butter wurden aus putins
ankündigungen verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit
und
diese verantwortung müssen wir klar
benennen unter dem vorwand die ukraine
von einem jüdischen präsidenten
entnazifizierung zu wollen
kopiert die russische soldat sk die
methoden der einsatzgruppen der
deutschen wehrmacht ss und der deutschen
polizei bei ihrem überfall auf die
ukraine das ist die realität vor der wir
stehen
natürlich michael roth hat recht niemand
da davon überrascht sein der boss nie
gesehen hat der aleppo der club gesehen
hat
aber ich muss da etwas hinzufügen
auch an uns alle und jenseits der
parteien
anfang der 2000er haben viele geglaubt
mit putin käme ein neuer peter der große
nach russland doch die russen haben
nicht wohlstand nicht modernisierung
erfahren im gegenteil ihnen wurde nur
nationalismus und gewalt geboten nicht
peter der große wladimir der
schreckliche ist in diesem europa
arbeiten
wir haben
uns auch geirrt
damit wird in dem denkt als wir geglaubt
haben man könnte so jemand mit
ökonomischen mitteln abschrecken putin
schert sich nicht um ökonomische
abschreckung der versteht nur die
abschreckung durch militär und gewalt
deswegen die 100 milliarden deswegen die
erhöhung der präsenz an der ostflanke
deswegen die waffenlieferung an die
ukraine aber wir müssen auch einen
anderen irrtum beenden den irrtum dass
wandel geschaffen wird durch handeln
wir haben die russischen banken vom
zahlungsverkehr abgeklemmt wir haben
gewusst zentralbank von der
währungsreserven abgeschnitten ist sind
die schärfsten finanzsanktionen verhängt
worden sind wir haben uns jetzt in
europa entschieden endlich sage ich
keine kohle mehr importieren zu wollen
deutschland arbeitet daran dass kein öl
mehr nach schmidt kommt wir arbeiten
daran unseren gast verbrauch zu
reduzieren belegen das paket vor das sie
endgültig rausholen aus fossilen
energien weil wir wissen nur wenn wir
erneuerbare energien schnell ausbauen
schaffen wir energiesicherheit und in
unserer abhängigkeit
aber meine damen und herren glaubt
eigentlich jemand dass wir das jemals
wieder rückgängig machen werden nein das
werden wir nicht deswegen sollten wir
aufhören von sanktionen zu sprechen was
hier stattfindet ist nichts anderes als
die abkopplung russlands von den märkten
europas von den märkten der usa die
abkopplung von den märkten der g7
staaten darum geht es wir schicken dass
russland von vladimir tim schrecklichen
zurück in die zeit der 60er jahre des
letzten jahrhunderts das ist das woran
wir arbeiten
und ich muss ein letztes hinzufügen
meine damen und herren wir
dürfen keine dieser morde vergessen
keiner dieser mörder darf straffrei
ausgehen das schulden wir den opfern
ihren familien und ihren freunden das
ist der grund warum wir alles tun werden
zusammen mit der beauftragten für
menschenrechte dem internationalen
strafgerichtshof beweise zu sichern
und die verantwortlichen auch
tatsächlich vor gericht zu bringen wir
müssen eines aus dieser geschichte der
gewalt doch gelernt haben
straffreiheit für verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit ist beihilfe dies müssen
wir beenden und wir müssen klar sagen
es gibt eine nur eine wirkliche
botschaft ausputzer
beenden sie diesen krieg ziehen sie die
russischen truppen aus der ukraine ab
der appell gegen trittin
außenpolitischer sprecher der grünen
fraktion hier im deutschen bundestag
eine aktuelle stunde auf die sich hier
die abgeordneten geeinigt haben noch ist
unklar wie groß das ausmaß
dessen ist was dort wirklich in dieser
stadt im nordwesten von hier
passiert ist dass sie würden sich in den
nächsten wochen vielleicht aber auch
erst im monat unterzeichnet die nächste
rednerin in dieser debatte ist renate
alt vorsitzender des ausschusses für
menschenrechte und humanitäre hilfe
am 6 märz besetzten die russischen
truppen das dorf marcel circa 50 km
nordwestlich von kiew sie warfen eine
nebelkerze in den keller eines gebäudes
in dem mehrere zivilisten schutz vor dem
schweren beschuss suchten als eine frau
und ein 14 jähriges mädchen aus dem
keller raus kamen schossen die russische
soldaten auf die beiden das kind starb
auf der stelle
die frau erlag ihren verletzungen zwei
tage später
das ist nur einer von mehreren dutzend
berichten der augenzeugen
die human rights watch inzwischen in der
ukraine sammeln konnte meine damen und
herren die bilder aus butter und anderen
vororten von herrlich kreativ und tief
sind eine zäsur nach dem was dort
passiert ist wird es kein zurück mehr
zum business as usual mit putins
russland geben
kriegsverbrechen der russischen armee
müssen geahndet werden wir haben
geschaut als großen dem boden
gleichgemacht wurde wir haben
weggeschaut als zivilisten im syrischen
außen massakriert wurden viel schlimmer
noch an dem ersten tag des russischen
überfalls auf die ukraine gab es
berichte von kriegsverbrechen von
zerstörter zilien infrastruktur von
beschossenen humanitärer konvois vom
bombardement der geburtsklinik im mai
geworden nach mutter muss jetzt
entschlossen gehandelt werden wir müssen
jetzt eine totale wirtschaftliche
isolation russland anstreben es geht
aber nicht nur darum druck auf das
libysche regime zu erhöhen die täter
müssen zur rechenschaft gezogen werden
die verbrechen die schon jetzt von
menschenrechtlern genannt werden um
fassung vergewaltigungen willkürlicher
hinrichtungen
gewalt gegen zivilisten plünderungen und
folter je mehr ukrainische orte befreit
werden desto mehr bilder wie die
ausrutscher sind leider zu erwarten
russische entscheidungsträger und
offiziere die diese gräueltaten
zugelassen oder angeordnet haben haben
das kriegsrecht mit füßen getreten sie
haben das humanitäre völkerrecht und die
genfer konvention aber auch das
internationale besetzungsrecht auf
gröbste verletzt die strafrechtliche
verantwortlichkeit für diese gräueltaten
erfordert beweise die den standards von
veh gerichtsverfahren standhalten die
ukraine kann zu einem wendepunkt in der
dokumentation von krebs kriegsverbrechen
werden es gibt kaum einen krieg beiden
beweise von kriegsverbrechen so früh und
so genau gesammelt wurden die mutigen
ukrainischen beamten lokale
zivilgesellschaftlichen gruppen die in
belagerten städten und ortschaften tätig
sind riskieren ihr leben um diesen krieg
jetzt zu dokumentieren sie haben
menschenrechtsorganisationen und open
source forschen an ihrer seite ihren
allen gebührt unser größter respekt
allen muss klar sein jeder journalist in
jeder kameramann vor ort riskiert sein
leben unsere aufgabe ist jetzt beim
festhalten der beweise zu helfen
deutschland sollte die kommissionen und
angels beim sammeln der daten
unterstützen den open source und
digitaler forensikern müssen wir
plattformen geben damit sie ihre
erfahrungen bei untersuchungen aus
früheren konflikten austauschen können
internationale ermittler müssen darin
geschult werden die open source beweise
eingesetzt werden können technische
ausrüstung statt eliten bilder digitale
infrastruktur wir müssen helfen wo es
nur geht meine damen und herren butscher
ist ein wendepunkt und jetzt müssen wir
parallel zu allen sanktionen zu
jeglichem tue alles dafür tun dass
russische soldaten bad vor nationalen
und internationalen gerichten stellen
[Applaus]
und ich erteile das wort michel
müntefering spd fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine eltern
wollten schon immer ein haus kaufen in
butter balles so nah dran ist an käßmann
mit dem auto in die hauptstadt pendeln
kann wie viele diplomaten und manche
abgeordnete butscher und sator in die
hauptstadt es war eine schöne stadt
erzählt mir gestern eine junge
ukrainerin das leid den schrecken all
das kann sie kaum fassen sie sieht die
bilder von herrn aus von meiner
heimatstadt aus dem ruhrgebiet wo sie
einen sicheren ort gefunden hat der
preis dafür alleine gehen die familie
dem schicksal überlassen das schicksal
das ist die russische aggression putins
völkerrechtswidriger krieg es ist
richtig dass heute angesichts der
ereignisse der letzten tage noch einmal
ganz deutlich wird wir hier stehen an
der seite der ukraine
sie bringt er kennt keine gewinner krieg
ist das unmenschlichste dass menschen
geschaffen haben alle bemühungen ihn
regeln zu unterwerfen im völkerrecht
kriegsrecht einzubetten ihn zu erklären
zu zügeln zu bändigen ihn in grenzen zu
halten ihn auf militärische kräfte zu
beschränken sein schrecken bleibt liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen in butter sehen
wir auf grausamste art und weise was
kriege niemals dürfen vergehen an frauen
kindern alten kranken gefangene
gefoltert vergewaltigt getötet sie
gehören zur zivilgesellschaft
präsident putin verbieten sie ihren
soldaten diese gräueltaten klar und
öffentlich noch heute lassen sie waffen
schweigen beenden sie den krieg ziehen
sie alle ihre truppen aus der ukraine ab
wenn es kein mitleid ist dass sie
aufbringen können dann haben sie
vielleicht ein letztes bisschen
ehrgefühl nicht unter den schlimmsten
verbrechen der menschheit in die
geschichtsbücher einzugehen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und wir
müssen jetzt noch mehr tun denn wer nach
gut schaut ja der muss auch in andere
städte schauen nach ihrer pin oder
gospel städte in denen früher viele
menschen lebten die in kiew arbeiteten
viele städte ihre bewohner im nordwesten
von kiew haben unter den verbrechen der
russischen armee gelitten die auf ihrem
weg eine spur der verwüstung hinterlässt
human rights watch born band dass es
ähnliche gewaltexzesse in anderen
städten gibt die gräuel sie müssen
aufgeklärt werden sie brauchen eine
klare antwort und ich bin unserem
bundeskanzler olaf scholz dankbar der
hier übrigens heute sitzt und sich
erklärt hat und uns zuhört liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich bin unseren
bundeskanzler dann zwar dass er deutlich
gemacht wir schauen nicht tatenlos zu
wir helfen es ist richtig dass die eu
weitere sanktionen verhängen will dass
angehörige der russischen botschaft zu
unerwünschten personen erklärt worden
sind die hier bei uns gegen uns
gearbeitet haben es braucht aber mehr
und einiges ist angesprochen worden ich
meine den zugang für internationale
organisationen zu den gebieten um die
gräueltaten unabhängig zu dokumentieren
die täter ja sie müssen zur rechenschaft
gezogen werden die bundesregierung
sollte auch den internationalen
strafgerichtshof finanziell stärken wir
müssen in der eu eine eigene kapazität
schaffen um zu helfen diese verbrechen
aufzuklären die oligarchen sie müssen
gestoppt werden über alle wege über
scheinfirmen und ähnliches die
sanktionen zu umgehen und ja wir müssen
europäisch koordinieren wie wir aus dem
russischen energieimporten aussteigen
wir müssen raus aus russischer energie
aus kohle öl und gas in stufen aber so
schnell es irgend geht nicht zuletzt
muss sich die ukraine wehren und
verteidigen können ich habe in die
listen über die waffenlieferungen in der
geheimschutzstelle einsicht genommen und
ich kann sagen das ist eine deutliche
entwicklung in den letzten wochen echte
unterstützung das ist gut das ist
richtig danke auch dafür ich würde mir
wünschen dass auch weitere
hilfsleistungen aus anderen häusern für
die abgeordneten in aller in voller
transparenz
koordiniert zur verfügung gestellt
werden denn das brauchen wir auch als
grundlage für unsere diskussion hier
klar ist die ukraine braucht jetzt für
die verteidigung auch weitere
waffenlieferungen solche die schnell
verfügbar die schnell einsetzbar sind
und wir werden jetzt auch mit unseren
partnern uns darauf einstellen müssen
der ukraine nicht nur den arm zu stärken
sondern auch den rücken die ukraine
braucht unsere solidarität aber auch in
zukunft alle kraft zur
selbstverteidigung herzlichen dank
die wir von michel müntefering
aus der spd-fraktion der bundesregierung
liegen mittlerweile auch schon belege
dafür vor dass es sich bei den tötungen
von zivilisten handelt dass es sich hier
um kriegsverbrechen handelt so hat ist
mittlerweile auch der regierungssprecher
bestätigt kolleginnen und kollegen die
bilder die wir täglich sehen sind
schockierend die ukraine muss sich gegen
einen brutalen angriffskrieg gegen
schrecklichste kriegsverbrechen zur wehr
setzen mutige ukrainerinnen ukraine
stehen an der front in der direkten
militärischen auseinandersetzung aber
angegriffen wurde nicht nur die ukraine
angegriffen wurde ganz europa und das
meine damen und herren muss auch
wirklich jeder in unserem land verstehen
dass wir uns es nicht einfach weiter
bequem machen können während in jeder
minute menschen in ukraine sterben und
darauf darf selbstverständlich auch der
ukrainische botschafter andere mendig
hinweisen den markt hier kritisieren der
unbequem ist auch für uns aber dem ich
danke dass er in dieser schrecklichen
situation in dieser lage in der sein
land ist die bestmögliche unterstützung
für sein land erreichen will
meine damen und herren
roger war ein zivilisationsbruch
botschaft sich ein in die schwersten
kriegsverbrechen in europa ein schauder
hafte abgründe von denen wir ausgingen
dass wir sie in europa nie wieder haben
werden ganze familien auf offener straße
erschossen für nichts ganze dörfer
ausgelöscht für nichts ganze landstriche
verwüstet für nichts liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
wieso lassen wir es zu dass aus dem nie
wieder ein schon wieder in europa
geworden ist und es stehen schlimmste
wochen bevor die ukrainische regierung
hat vor kurzem vor wenigen momenten
aufgerufen die ost ukraine zu verlassen
die zivilbevölkerung zu zu evakuieren
wegen der erwarteten
großoffensive und da ersten letztlich
nur
entsprechende verteidigungsfähigkeit wir
müssen endlich alles dafür tun dass
dieser kriegsverbrecher putin gestoppt
wird und da muss ich ehrlich sagen
da muss ich ehrlich sagen meine damen
und herren ist die zögerlichkeit dieser
bundesregierung wenn vielen fragen nicht
zu ertragen wie damals opposition gesagt
dass wir die regierung unterstützt in
allem was sie tut um diesen krieg zu
stoppen aber können natürlich nicht das
nichtstun unterstützen ich finde wichtig
der bundeskanzler dass sie zu dieser
aktuellen stunde gekommen sind
aber jetzt vorher bei der fragestunde
sich hinzustellen und sagen dass diese
regierung schließlich macht waffen
liefert was die vorherige nicht gemacht
hat das ist zu wenig weil man muss
natürlich gemessen werden an der
situation in der wir sind und frau
verteidigungsministerin das ist kein
überzeugendes bild das sie abgegeben
geheimhaltung kam kein feigenblatt für
untätigkeit sein meine damen und
dass
das ist ja kein bild das wir uns
ausdenken sondern es sind einfach die
fragmente die wir aus europa aus der
ukraine bekommen die dieses bild
zusammensetzen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
führung bedeutet ein klares ziel zu
formulieren und das muss sein russland
darf diesen krieg nicht militärisch
gewinnen russland der ukraine
militärisch nicht erfolgreich sein und
diesem ziel müssen wir unser handeln
entsprechend ausrichten und das bedeutet
auch dass wir in der lage ankommen dass
wir nicht mit unserer 9 bis 16 uhr
bürokratie er unterwegs sein können das
heißt konkret dass wir akzeptieren dass
dieser krieg nicht den wochen vorbei
sein wird das heißt konkret dass auch
schwere waffen einbezogen werden müssen
es ist unverständlich dass diese bisher
immer von den listen gestrichen worden
sind und verantwortung zwischen
verteidigungsministerium und kanzleramt
hin und hergeschoben wird dem ziel alles
und worten heißt konkret dass wir auch
schwere waffen westlicher bauart
brauchen werden um meine damen und
herren es ist eine entscheidung der
freunde in der ukraine
ob sie diese personelle und zeitliche
investition tätigen wollen und keine
frage von uns wir müssen uns darüber
wenig gedanken machen alles dem ziel
dass russland nicht erfolgreich ist
unterordnen heißt auch konkret dass es
nicht wochen dauern kann bis
genehmigungen erteilt werden für gerät
welches in unserer rüstungsindustrie
verfügbar ist und sofort geliefert
werden kann und es ist auch wichtig das
heißt konkret dass wir das signal geben
dass die internationale gemeinschaft
waffen munition
betriebsstoffe liefert so lange es nötig
ist meine damen und herren
roger war aus sicht von wladimir putin
nur der anfang er will die ukraine
auslöschen er will ukraine vernichten
putin hat das öffentlich gesagt wir
müssen ihm beim wort nehmen ich rufe
dazu auf dass wir wirklich alles tun
acht zu verhindern ich glaube die
bundesregierung auf legen sie das zögern
abgehen sie beherzt voran dann haben sie
auch unsere unterstützung herzlichen
dank
thomas erne fordert hier ein beherztes
vorangehen und während hier diese
debatte läuft hat die usa neue
sanktionen gegen russland angekündigt
unter anderem sollen zwei große
russische banken und die erwachsenen
kindern des russischen präsidenten
wladimir putin von diesen strafmaßnahmen
betroffen sein
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren liebe demokratinnen und
demokraten und andere als mutter und 13
menschenrechtspolitiker schnitt ist mir
die kehle zu wenn ich die bilder der
ermordeten zivilistinnen in butter c die
berichte über 100 meter in den käfer
vorstädten boccia und kostümen und der
fund von zahlreichen leichen in
massengräbern all das weist verweis auf
ein grausames massaker an der
zivilbevölkerung
frauen kinder alte
hingerichtet
die ukrainische abgeordnete in erfassung
berichtet dass auch leichname von
kindern mit verbundenen händen gefunden
wurden ca ein bestatter aus butter
erzählt in der taz dass sie über 300
leichen geborgen hätten circa 30 prozent
seien frauen und kinder gewesen vielen
waren die hände auf dem rücken
zusammengebunden ist und bleibt in
erträglich das sind keine bilder aus der
vergangenheit das geschieht heute
vielleicht sogar jetzt während wir hier
über diese kreuz haben debattieren
ebenso schlimm finde ich es dass es auch
bei uns in deutschland menschen gibt die
diese gräueltaten als inszenierung der
ukrainischen regierung abstreiten und
das ausmaß der unmenschlichkeit in frage
stellen sie gehen demonstrierend auf
unsere straßen und nutzen das
demonstrationsrecht aus was in russland
verwehrt wird
es gibt leider auch mandatsträger und
kandidierenden die dieses in zweifel
stellen nicht umsonst wirklich in ihre
richtung und ich würde sie bitten lieber
fdp fraktion ihren dresdner
ob-kandidaten mal ein bisschen zu zügeln
danke
die
propagandamaschinerie des grand scheint
nämlich auch hier zu verfangen dabei
müsste man sich nur auf der offiziellen
nachrichten website der russischen
regierung und schauen die russische
föderation macht kein hehl daraus warum
es ihnen wirklich geht ich zitiere
ukraine müssen so zahlreich wie möglich
getötet werden nicht nur die eliten die
meisten menschen sind schuldig sie sind
passiver nazis zynischer geht's wirklich
kaum noch ein friedliches
prosperierendes land wie die ukraine das
seine atomwaffen 94 an russland
abgegeben hat dass die grundwerte der eu
anerkennt ein land in die überlebende
der
nationalsozialistischen
vernichtungslager durch russischen
raketen beschluss ermordet werden ein
land mit einem jüdischen präsidenten an
seiner spitze und ein land in dem seit
30 jahren die rechtsradikalen parteien
und kräfte dort scheitern rechtsextreme
meist an der fünf-prozent-hürde ihr
leider nicht ein solches land verdient
nicht nur unsere solidarität sondern es
hat auch sandplatz in europa in der
europäischen union verdient in freiheit
und an unserer seite
die
die transportierten april berichtet von
einem grab das in einem nachbardorf von
butscher gefunden wurde in diesem grab
liegen zwei frauen und vier männer alle
mit schüssen in den hinterkopf
exekutiert das ist die familie der
dorfvorsteher gas zu schenkungen sie und
ihre familie sind seit dem 23
märz verschwunden sie war eine
kommunalpolitikerin wie viele von uns ja
auch die sich dem militär nicht beugen
wollten dafür wurden sie und ihre
familie entführt und menschenverachtend
kritisiert die bürgermeisterin gehörte
zur funktionseliten eines landes ans
landes dem präsident putin die
existenzberechtigung wieder gut
abgesprochen hat die opfer von butter
sind nicht den entgleisungen einzeln
dazu zu rechnen die durch den
traumatischen erfahrung und des traums
des krieges durchdrehen nein sie sind
die tafel eines mordende ziel morgen den
militärapparats der vom kreml aus
befehligt und befeuert wird wird es nun
von butscher wie viele butchers es
tatsächlich sind in denen das russische
militär zivilistinnen ermordet
verschleppt und gefoltert hat das wissen
wir zu diesem zeitpunkt noch nicht sehr
geehrte damen und herren ich fordere
analog zur un menschenrechtskommissarin
michele bachelet eine unabhängige
untersuchung in der ukraine
dazu gehört eine umfassende
beweissicherung und
exhumierung und identifizierung aller
leichenfunde
werden der terror sät wird die
entschlossenheit der internationalen
justiz ernten der kriegsverbrechen
legitimiert und relativiert macht sich
mitschuldig bis es jedoch soweit ist bis
alles aufgeklärt es müssen sie diesen
politischen und wirtschaftlichen druck
oft putin maximal verstärken bei
kriegsverbrechen gibt es nicht mehr
allzu viel zu diskutieren mit zwei
zahlen von danger
möchte ich schließen faschisten hören
niemals auch faschisten zu sein man
diskutiert mit ihnen nicht das hat die
geschichte gezeigt nicht diskutieren
sanktionieren danke dass sie das tun die
war bundeskanzler liebe bundesregierung
danke
[Applaus]
damit beenden wir die aktuelle stunde
und führen fahren unsere tagesordnung
fort